Bruce Lee's daughter is none too pleased
with Quentin Tarantino's newest movie
Shannon Lee the 50 year old daughter at
the late martial arts master recently
opened up to say how disheartening it
was to see what she described as the
mockery Tarantino's once upon a time in
Hollywood made of her father an actor
director martial artists and philosopher
Bruce Lee was one of the many real-life
icons featured in Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood a film that explores Los
Angeles in 1969 around the time of the
gruesome Manson family murders within
the flake Street Fighter assassin's fist
actor Mike Mo portrays Lee scene
opposite Brad Pitt's fictional stuntman
carets XF booth on the set of the real
action-adventure television series The
Green Hornet the two men battle
backstage as others look on Lee wins the
first round of the fight while booth
shoves Lee against a car in the second
the third round is interrupted before a
victor can be crowned Shannon Lee told
The Wrap that I can understand all the
reasoning behind what is portrayed in
the movie I understand that the two
characters are anti heroes and this is
sort of like a rage fantasy of what
would happen I understand they want to
make the Brad Pitt character the super
badass who could beat up Bruce Lee but
they didn't need to treat him the way
that white Hollywood did when he was
alive she later speculated that perhaps
once upon a time in Hollywood was trying
to offer commentary in the ways in which
Hollywood falsely stereotypes lay but
Tarantino failed on that front
Shannon added that Lee wasn't interested
in fighting outside of martial arts and
actively avoided conflicts he comes
across as an arrogant who was full of
hot air
and not someone who had to fight triple
as hard as any of those people did to
accomplish what was naturally given to
so many others it was really
uncomfortable to sit in the theatre and
listen to people laugh at my father she
also pointed out an inaccuracy in Lee's
physical appearance on the film he was
shown with a haircut and sunglasses
characteristic of the 1970s while the
Green Hornet's editor in 1967 and 1968
Shannon who is just four years old when
her father passed away in 1973 has kept
Lee's legacy alive to the website Bruce
Lee calm a podcast and the Bruce Lee
foundation she continued to say that
what I'm interested in is raising the
consciousness of who Bruce Lee was as a
human being and how he lived his life
all of that was flushed down the toilet
in this portrayal
however Shannon Lee added that she
didn't find fault in most performance as
a late father she stated that she
believes he was quote directed to be a
caricature but still
praised him for capturing Lee's
mannerisms and voice for Shannon it was
especially difficult seeing the way her
father was portrayed in once upon a time
in Hollywood given that other real-life
celebrities in the film were
characterized but not mocked
Shannon wasn't the only person who took
issue with Lee's portrayal in the
Tarantino directed film Matthew Polly
author of Bruce Lee alive told The Wrap
that he had his own issues with leads to
picture Bruce revered Muhammad Ali he
never trash talk Tim in real life Bruce
never used jumping kicks in an actual
fight and even if he did there wasn't a
stuntman in hollywood fast enough to
catch his leg and throw him into a car
Tarantino has a penchant for revising
history and clearly kept that passion
burning and once upon a time in
Hollywood though his decisions clearly
didn't sit well with Shannon Lee or
Matthew Poly with any luck Tarantino
will hear the criticism and bear it in
mind for his tenth and potentially final
film check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
but your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the BAL so you don't miss a single one
[Music]